[Music]
you know if that coaster coming again
yeah thanks have you thing out there
we'll talk more when you come up next
week
[Applause]
hey honey Shh
what's going on oh I was having a little
celebration it looks like I'm gonna get
that promotion to senior management no
way yeah Anthony
can I see you we haven't received your
tuition check for second semester I want
to stress out mom I know she's working
like a thousand hours weeks yeah you did
the right thing
what's happening on the college friend
you have the talent Anthony instead of
getting big in the big moment good small
I played hard for my scholarships I'm
looking for someone who will stand out
we need one that's our white boy feel
that anger
long time no talk Michigan State's
playing at home there's no way to know
whose I know you drained the college
account how much do I put down how much
do you owe you want me to wait around to
you feel like you can share anything
with me it's all gonna work out for the
best
you always think that
we hit it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so it's true that's her spot I heard
some 10th graders worship you talking
about it yeah this is my spot kind of
you know they've come down here and they
pretend to be you it's actually kind of
lame its lamé is having to take Jim as a
senior I'm sorry I'm sorry
what are both him what nothing he's just
asking how it's going
everybody loves Anthony
I don't understand you
I'm sorry
for what
being a shitty boyfriend do your see
yeah I just said yeah I wanted to say
too
you